AND HE SAID,
MR. BA-BA-BA-BA,
THERE'S A WARRANT OUT
FOR YOUR ARREST.
YOU'RE UNDER ARREST
FOR THE BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
AND HE WAS, LIKE, SO [bleep]
THAT HE WAS LIKE,
OKAY, LIKE...
SOMETHING'S HAPPENING.
SO I GOTTA, LIKE, KINDA SAY,
HEY, WHAT'S GOING ON?
SO HE MOVED.
AND AS SOON AS HE MOVED,
THEY--
BOOM, BOOM, BOOM--
TACKLED HIM.
WHAT WAS SO CRAZY WAS--
OKAY, SO THEY, LIKE, CALLED
THE OTHER GUY ON SECURITY.
HE--THEY HAD HIM
CALL ON SECURITY AND SAY,
YOU--YOU NEED TO COME DOWN HERE.
SOMETHING'S HAPPENING, LIKE--
[ominous music]
♪
SO THEY TAPED HIM UP,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
DUCT TAPED THEIR MOUTHS.
THEY REALIZED THAT ISABEL
WAS SO SMART IN HER TIME
THAT SHE, LIKE,
LITERALLY, LIKE,
SECURED THE ART
TO THE WALL.
THEY PANICKED!
THEY PANICKED! THEY PANICKED!
OH, [bleep].
WE GOTTA GET OUTTA THERE.
SO WHAT WAS
EVEN CRAZIER WAS,
THEY TOOK A KNIFE
AND JUST WENT LIKE,
[bleep] YOU!
LIKE, BOOM, BOOM,
BOOM, BOOM!
CRAZY, YOU KNOW?
LIKE, THEY WERE JUST LIKE,
[bleep] IT.
THEY WERE LIKE IDIOTS.
THEY CUT IT OUT!
AND WERE LIKE,
OH, LET'S ROLL IT OUT
AND SELL IT ON, LIKE,
CANAL STREET IN NEW YORK.
- LIKE, THEY TOOK OUT
RAZOR BLADES?
- YEAH, SO [bleep], LIKE--
- CUT THE ART OFF.
- LIKE...
THUG, LIKE, NATION.
SO THESE GUYS GO THROUGH.
THEY STEAL, LIKE, HUNDREDS
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WORTH OF ART.
SO THIS FBI GUY CAME IN,
AND PEOPLE REPORTED THESE GUYS
WERE, LIKE, AROUND 35 YEARS OLD,
LIKE, 5', LIKE, 10".
LIKE, THESE POLICEMEN
THAT GOT IN THIS CAR--
IT'S INSANE,
LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LIKE, IT'S CRAZY.
AND HE'S LIKE,
I'VE SEEN REMBRANDTS APPEAR
AT THESE CHINESE RESTAURANTS
IN THE BATHROOM BEFORE.
OR, I'VE BEEN IN PARIS,
WHERE I'VE BEEN
IN THIS UNDERGROUND TUNNEL,
AND THERE'S BEEN
A PICTURE OF MONET.